The fourth topic I'd like you to be aware of is the Abstraction Mechanisms which
you can bring to bear in solving problems. As I indicated at the start of
the course, the key element in success in doing design, is having experience in
solving similar problems. The way that the human mind stores this experience is
in terms, of chunks or vocabulary, such as words like client server,
or visitor pattern. This Vocabulary can be thought of at different levels. So
at one end are, programming idioms that is snippets of program text which,
it's almost as if you've memorized in order to accomplish some specific task.
Classes of course are an Abstraction Mechanism, and being aware of
whatever Classes are available to you in system libraries can ease your task of,
of constructing the application. A little while later we're going to be talking
about design patterns and I mentioned one a second ago the visitor pattern.
Being aware of those already existing solutions can help you avoid problems. And
we'll be talking in this course about aspects but aspect orientated programming
is a way of specifically dealing with cross cutting concerns.
We'll also won't be talking much about object orientated frameworks. Well,
they too are existing patterns of solutions which, if you are aware of them,
can significantly increase your productivity. And, as we've
already talked about, architectural styles, [UNKNOWN] approaches to solutions at
the architectural level, are a powerful mechanism you want to be familiar with.